Rolo replacing the Constitution left
behind by Chile's former military
dictatorship is turning out to be much
more difficult than anyone could have
predicted
Chileans went back to the polls Sunday
to elect a new constitutional Council
that they hoped would do a better job
than the previous one whose draft
Charter they rejected last September for
being too radical we need to reach a
balance a consensus so that everyone is
happy with the results unlike last time
more equality more modern rules with a
more modern vision of society in the
Constitution that's what I hope for but
that's unlikely to happen if the
previous Council was dominated by the
far left this time it will be under the
control of the right and far right
together they've clinched more than 30
of the 50 delegate seats enough to pass
any constitutional Norm they propose on
their own
Chile's Republican party the most
conservative of all will now be the
leading political force
and their most voted candidate Luis
Silva told me they've never wanted to
replace the dictatorship era
Constitution
it is our starting point this process
allows us to introduce new aspects to it
that we believe our constitution
deserves
we can modernize fundamental rights like
honor privacy internet issues and
measures to stabilize our political
system
the result could have been different but
20 of votes were null or blank ballots
believed to have been cast mostly by
Progressive Chileans who were unhappy
with the process
team of legal experts appointed by
Congress has already presented moderate
proposals that include better
recognition of social rights such as
Education Health Care and pensions but
these can be modified or rejected by the
new body
the council will have a very short time
to draft the charter only four months
then it will be put to the vote again in
a referendum on December 17th
now wanting to
a long long time to finally eliminate
the last important symbol of its former
military dictatorship and it would be an
irony particularly this year as Chile
commemorates the 50th anniversary of the
coup that gave birth to the Constitution
that so many find illegitimate Lucia
Newman Al Jazeera Santiago thank you